shoes
i don't think that's been locked
all right
this is
so
hey
yeah okay everybody
everybody okay
whoa no debbie's in michigan
with uh vice president
soon to be my vice president
okay good afternoon everybody thank you
for being here i'm proud to be joined by
my
colleagues uh in in
our caucus and our leadership team dick
durbin and patty murray
now right over there
thousands have come to the steps of the
highest court
to pay tribute to justice ginsburg
she was an amazing lady and it is
in a male-dominated world of
all these legal giants she was smarter
than they were she was more persistent
than they were
and she accomplished much more than they
did
and i admire her and i come from her
neighborhood
and as a neighborhood boy we feel pride
in someone doing so much
in our neighborhood we both are
graduates of james madison high school
brooklyn new york
so my colleagues so so many have paid
tribute
to come to the steps of the highest
court
to pay tribute to justice ginberg
ginsburg
but my senate colleagues have paid
tribute as well
but in words only empty words
because their actions haven't republican
majority leader
mcconnell likes to say he's a senate
institutionalist
nothing could be further from the truth
he has defiled the senate
in recent history leader mcconnell's
actions may now very well
destroy the institution of the senate
if leader mcconnell presses forward
republican the republican majority will
have stolen
two supreme court seats four years apart
using completely contradictory
rationales
this was mcconnell's rule when merrick
garland was nominated
by president obama the american people
should have a voice in the selection of
their next supreme court justice
therefore this vacancy should not be
filled
until we have a new president
certainly isn't implying now
leader mcconnell has basically decided
the rules don't apply to republicans
even their own rules it's just brute
political force
if that becomes the standard in the
senate how can we expect to trust the
other side again
why should the american people trust
the republican senators to do anything
they say when they are proving right now
that their speeches mean nothing the
moment the shoe is on the other foot
senate republicans should heed leader
mcconnell's own words from 2013.
quote he said you'll regret this and you
may regret this a lot sooner
than you think the american people
don't want republicans to move forward
with a confirmation
they know this is wrong a reuters poll
reads it showed 62 percent of americans
said the vacancy
left by justice ginsburg's passing
should be filled by the candidate
who wins on november third the next
supreme court justice of course we know
could change the complexion of the court
for a generation
and their decisions will touch every
aspect of american life
but if republicans say the heck with it
we don't care
about anything the rules the senate the
institution and just move
forward everything americans value hangs
in the balance
health care protections for pre-existing
conditions
women's rights gay rights workers rights
labor rights voting rights civil rights
climate change and so much else
is at risk the entire affordable care
act
and protections for up to 130 million
americans
with pre-existing conditions hangs in
the balance
a woman's fundamental constitutional
right
to make her own medical decisions the
right to choose
for the first time in decades hangs in
the balance
the right of workers to organize and
collectively bargain for fair wages
hangs in the balance the future of our
planet
environmental protections and the
possibility of bold legislation to
address climate change
as well as the clean air and clean water
acts hang
in the balance voting rights
and the right of every american citizen
to have a voice in our democracy
hangs in the balance and so much more
and on every one of these issues what
the republicans have done
is they have pulled the federal
judiciary
to their far right side now they want to
tilt the supreme court even further away
so it doesn't reflect the values
of the majority of americans it reflects
the values of an extreme
right-wing majority
we've seen this play out over and over
again
republicans at the same time as they are
rushing through a supreme court nominee
they're doing nothing about the covet
crisis
it's been four months since the house
passed
its heroes act mcconnell had a pause
he wanted to assess the situation then
he put a bill on the floor that was so
emaciated it did hardly anything
and now they're ignoring covid
and his huge crisis once again to try
and rush through a supreme court nominee
and at the same time senate republicans
in this administration have demonstrated
they can't be trusted to protect the
american people
that's why senator murray and i
introduced the science transparency over
politics act the stop act to establish
essential oversight of the coronavirus
response
the bill would create a task force to
report to the public when politics are
behind coveted response decisions
rather than republicans just letting
scientists do their work
you'll hear a lot more about that from
senator murray
but we democrats are fighting as hard as
we can
to protect americans and we need
americans to
[Music]
stop lying to the people jesus loves you
guys
thank you democrats are fighting as hard
as we can to protect
americans but we need americans to
continue to fight with us
to keep holding republican senators
accountable
senator durbin i got it
you want to put that thing
i want to thank you senator schumer uh
when we used to do tours the capitol
people would point out one of the rooms
in there and say that's the senate
but they were wrong it's just a room the
senate is a hundred men and women who
come together
with a constitutional responsibility and
the only way that they can actually be a
senate
is if they have some basic
understandings understandings of history
tradition the rules and mutual respect
what we see happening in the senate
today with senator mcconnell's decision
to reverse his position of four years
ago and to push through the vacancy
filling nominee of the trump
administration is really is an assault
on all of those things
history tradition rules and the mutual
respect
of the united states senate we've
watched as his colleagues have come
forward and squirmed away from their
positions of four years ago which kept
garland's name from even being
considered in a hearing
and here today we face another issue not
just who's going to win
this verbal battle over how to choose
the nominee to fill
the vacancy but who is going to lead on
this supreme court across the street
most of the people i represent in
illinois i know the supreme court's
important but if you ask them why is it
important to you personally
they'd be a little hard-pressed to come
up with an answer there is an easy
answer
today because we have 20 million
americans who are protected by the
affordable care act
we know that this protection is at risk
in the supreme court and the supreme
court majority is at risk
for the tactics of mitch mcconnell
we also know the protection on
pre-existing conditions is particularly
relevant today
in the middle of this covet 19 crisis
over 6 million americans have already
been diagnosed as positive
some of them will be lucky and get over
it and go right about their business
many will carry problems with them for a
long period of time
and trust me if the insurance companies
were given the power they had before the
affordable care act
those people those who tested positive
will be people with pre-existing
conditions who will pay more for their
insurance if they can even buy it
that's the reality of the future of the
affordable care act the role of the
supreme court
and the political debate taking place on
the floor of the united states senate
what's at stake here is not just the
senate and not just the supreme court
but whether or not we will stand up for
the history rules and traditions of the
senate
and most importantly for mutual respect
of members
what senator mcconnell is putting the
senate through now is so destructive
for those of us who've been there for a
while we knew a different senate
under different leadership we need to
return to that if the american people
are going to have their
respect restored in this institution in
this government and the decisions we
make
we have to prove it and we do it by
living up to our word of four years ago
and saying that this president shall not
choose the nominee
to fill the vacancy but the next
president whoever it may be
will have that opportunity senator
murray
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you senator durbin it seems
that
virtually every day there's a new report
of the trump administration
meddling in decisions that should be
driven by
public health and by science the stop
act which we introduced today
says enough is enough families and
communities are looking for
accurate information about how to make
the right decision for themselves
and their loved ones and they should be
able to trust
what they hear from their health
department this bill should not be one
bit controversial especially given how
many of our republican colleagues have
said
we need to be listening to the experts
and following the science
now they will have a chance to show they
mean it
with action another thing my republican
colleagues have repeatedly said is they
support protections
for pre-existing conditions well just
days after the election
the supreme court is scheduled to hear a
case that will decide the future
of health care in this country depending
on that decision
tens of millions of americans could lose
their health care
pre-existing conditions could go away
young adults on their parents coverage
could be kicked off
and i could say more keep in mind this
is in the middle of a still raging
pandemic that has cost 200 000
american lives caused millions of people
to lose their jobs
and left millions without health
insurance
and left people nationwide with after
effects of copin 19
that in itself could become a
pre-existing condition
so again when health care matters
perhaps more than it ever has
in the middle of a pandemic that is
costing lives and sickening people
nationwide
we still see republican leaders refusing
to stand
up to the president on issues as stark
as
political interference in a public
health agency
running roughshod over their own claims
they support protections for
pre-existing conditions
and ignoring the dire health and
economic impacts of this pandemic
all to jam a highly partisan judge
onto the supreme court through a highly
partisan process
as people in this country today are
already casting
their ballots in the upcoming election
democrats are not going to stop for a
minute over the next critical days and
weeks when it comes to holding them
to account for their hypocrisy and i
also want to add
i know this is an uphill battle but just
like when we defeated trumpcare when no
one thought we could
everyone who speaks up matters
every voice is going to make a
difference and we should
never underestimate that so to those out
there who care as much as we do
stand up speak out it makes a difference
thank you
[Music]
questions yes ma'am do you think that
this
sort of brings the importance of
elections and voting into focus
i mean the reason why there's likely
going to be a third conservative justice
in the court is because president trump
won the election
senate republicans won the majority what
is the message now to democrats in terms
of the importance of
winning elections it's not just a
message to democrats it's a message to
the american people
look sorry getting used to this um
it's a message to the american people
which is so much of what you value is at
stake and it affects individuals
my daughter and her wife were sitting
together at our rosh hashanah dinner
when we heard the news of
the terrible tragedy of justice
greenberg
ginsburg's passing and one of them
looked to the other and said do you
think our right to marry
they're married already but will be
preserved
so this matters to the american people
it's way beyond politics
but it means that if the american people
care about these issues they should let
their republican senators
who seem to be lining up lockstep
that they shouldn't be voting for this
nominee and then they have the
opportunity at the ballot box
just 40 some odd days away to change it
yes
doesn't just make an argument instead of
talking about a filibuster to return to
a 60 vote threshold where republicans
would have had to come to democrats for
this and will you do that if you get the
majority back
all i've said is our first job is to get
the majority back
and everything is on the table but it
was
everything is on the table we are going
to look at
how we can produce change
you and your colleagues all have friends
across you have
friends across the aisle colleagues that
you work with across the aisle
obviously you disagree on a lot of
things all of them except for a couple
are signing on to this does this affect
relationships within the senate
well it's hard particularly to so many
who
spoke so strongly before led by senator
mcconnell but including senator graham
when they do such an about face on such
an important issue that's so
dramatically
contradictory it it makes it hard
look we'll always have to try
and um but it's it's created a lot
of mistrust and ill feeling
in a way that i haven't seen it occur in
the senate in a very long time
yeah just just look at that it's
mcconnell who's changed the rules
not us
did the senate move too fast well i'd
have to go over the history there but it
wasn't
on the eve of an election like this
go ahead next question do you worry at
all that your language about
everything is on the table could be used
against some of your democratic senate
candidates everything is on the table
my senate democratic uh colleagues and
candidates
know america needs some change and we're
going to figure out the best way to do
it
yes next is there any nominee that
president trump could put forward that
senate democrats would eventually be
able to get behind
well you know right now they come from
the list
of the federalist society which has some
very strong
strict strictures and that makes it very
very difficult but you'd have to wait
and see each nominee the names we've
heard
are not acceptable at all not even close
let no
let's one one yes last question
uh we invoked the two-hour rule because
the
the we can't have business as usual when
republicans are destroying
the institution as they have done and
that's why we invoke the two-hour rule
thank you everybody jesus
jesus christ
hey i got to answer everybody to all
life's problems
his name is jesus christ look at me i'm
an african-american
i'm talking about a jew born in israel
his name is jesus
and he loves you guys i want to see all
y'all in heaven
and the only way you can come to heaven
is through
jesus
jesus saves um does anybody want to pray
for our nation
anybody want to pray for our nation
anybody want to join me in prayer for
our nation
we need god we need prayer
jesus saves
jesus saves
jesus christ merchandise
i have good news the king is coming
the king is coming
jesus is